how did homo sapiens
evolve if we think about the invention
of
early invention of sex and early
invention of predation
what was the thing invented
to make humans
well what would you say
i mean i suppose a couple of things i'd
say number one is you don't have to wind
the clock back very far
five six million years or so and and
and let it run forwards again and the
chances of
humans as we know them is not
necessarily that high
and you know imagine
as an alien you find planet earth and
it's got everything apart from humans on
it it's an amazing wonderful marvelous
planet but nothing that we would
recognize as
extremely intelligent life kind of
space-faring civilization so when we
think about aliens we we we're kind of
after something like ourselves or after
a space-faring civilization we're not
after
zebras and giraffes and lions and things
amazing though they are
but the
the additional kind of evolutionary
steps to go from
large complex mammals monkeys let's say
to
to humans
doesn't strike me as that longer
a distance is all about the brain and
where's the where's the brain and
morality coming from it seems to me
to be all about groups human groups and
interactions between groups the
collective intelligence of it
yes yeah the interactions really and
there's some there's a guy at ucl uh
called mark thomas who's done a lot of
really beautiful work i think on on this
kind of question so i talked to him
every now and then so my views are
influenced by him
but a lot seems to depend on population
density
that the more interactions you have
going on between different groups the
more transfer
of information if you like between
groups
of people moving from one group to
another group almost like lateral gene
transfer in bacteria
the more expertise you're able to
develop and maintain
the more
culturally complex your society can
become and groups that have become
detached um like on easter island for
example very often
degenerate in terms of the complexity of
their civilization is that true for
complex organisms in general population
density is often productive
really matters but in human terms
um
i don't know what the actual factors
were that were driving a a large brain
but you know you can you can talk about
fire you can talk about to use you can
talk about language and none of them
seem to correlate especially well with
the actual known trajectory of human
evolution in terms of
cave art and these kind of things that
that seems to work much better just with
with population density and in number of
interactions between different groups
all of which is really
about
human interactions human human
interactions and the complexity of those
but
population density is the thing that
increases the number of interactions but
then there must have been inventions
uh forced by that
number of interactions that actually led
to humans so like richard wrangham
talks about that
it's basically the beta males had to
beat up the alpha male so that's what
collaboration looks like is they when
you're living together they don't like
the
the our early ancestors
don't like the dictatorial aspect of a
single individual at the top of a tribe
so they uh they they learned to
collaborate how to
uh basically create a democracy uh of
sorts a democracy that prevents
minimizes or lessens the amount of
violence which essentially
gives strength to the tribe and make the
war between tribes
uh versus the dictator i mean i think
one of the most wonderful things about
humans is we're all of those things i
mean we are deeply social as a species
and we're also deeply selfish and it
seems to me the conflict between
capitalism and communism it's really
just two aspects of human nature both of
which are both we have both uh and we
have a constant kind of vying between
the two sides we we really do care about
other people beyond our families beyond
our immediate people we care about
society and the society that we live in
and and you could say that's a you know
a drawing towards socialism or communism
on the other side we really do care
about ourselves we really do care about
our families about working for something
that we gain from and that's the
capitalist side of it they're both
really deeply ingrained in human nature
in terms of violence um and and and
interactions between groups yes all this
dynamic of if you're interacting between
groups you can be certain that
they're going to be burning each other
and all kinds of interact physical
violent interactions as well which will
drive
the kind of cleverness of how do you
resist this let's build a tower let's
you know what are we going to do to to
to to prevent being overrun by those
marauding gangs from over there
um and you look you look outside humans
and you look at chimps and bonobos and
so on and they're very very different
structures to society chimps tend to
have an aggressive alpha male type
structure and bonobos
are you know they they there's basically
a female society where the males are
predominantly excluded and only brought
in at the behest of the female
we have a lot in common with both
both of those groups and there's again
tension there yeah and uh probably
chimps more violence the bonobos
probably more sex
that's another tension
[Laughter]
how serious do you wanna do do we wanna
be how much fun we wanna be
you